[Music]
one of the biggest movies of the summer
is opening this week the lone ranger
with johnny depp and armie hammer
yeah and we decided we wanted to find
out more about it so we sent our very
own andy richter to santa fe new mexico
for the lone ranger press junket to meet
the stars of the film how did it go andy
well you know okay
well did you get to meet all the stars
we did the best we could let me just say
that
all right i'm assuming this is excellent
let's take a look
[Music]
hi
i'm outside of santa fe new mexico for
the big walt disney pictures lone ranger
press junket
we got here a little late
they didn't have any slots for us so
apparently i just found out i won't be
interviewing johnny depp
i won't be interviewing army hammer they
said there's one star of the movie i
could interview though and
i guess we'll see how it goes
i'm here speaking to one of the stars
the lone ranger
hello silver
this is gonna be tough
so
according to my notes you've done a lot
of film and television work uh
care to comment on how any of that stuff
compares to your work on the lone ranger
[Laughter]
so you're 11 years old pretty young for
hollywood
is it tough to work in hollywood when
you're so young
you know you worry that you know you're
gonna
lindsay lohan at some point
who's a bigger jerk johnny depp or army
hammer
oh you're good
look i'm sorry this isn't working for me
i mean i came all the way to new mexico
to
interview the stars of the movie and i
can't get access to anybody and i i got
you and i mean you're great
believe me you're great and
i don't know i just this isn't what i
thought this would be
you know what i after this i'm done
how's your day you want you want to hang
out
all right let's get out of here
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh seriously i think this shirt looks
great
[Music]
oh calm down you're next
all right you ready for this
[Music]
you know this has been an amazing day i
did not think
that this was going to work out for me
at all i thought it was going to have a
lousy time and
i mean
little did i know that i would end up
making a new friend
wait
where are you going
wait come back
well
that's hollywood for you
[Music]
bunch of phonies
all right back to you conan this is andy
richter reporting from the lone ranger
junket in new mexico
andy
nice job what i'm really mad that we
didn't get a shot of him driving away
because he had a really nice car
sounds like a really uh sports car